démocratie participative développer le
vivre ensemble transition écologique et
devoir d'exemplarité
voici les principes du pacte
d'engagement municipal du modem un
document destiné aux candidates et
candidats qui souhaitent solliciter le
soutien du mouvement pour le scrutin en
2020 nous aujourd'hui on veut pas
aborder ces élections comme une élection
nationale je crois que les français les
hesdinois ne le souhaite pas c'est pas
une élection des sikhs est loin de là
aujourd'hui nous on veut bâtir des
rassemblements et porter des projets
pour les communes avec des partenaires
historiques et des nouveaux partenaires
ce qu'on veut faire surtout c'est porter
des projets citoyens dans les communes
et poursuivre le maillage territorial
pour le pour le moment à ce jour dans
les communes de plus de 9000 habitants
19 chefs de file ont été désignés ils
ont un rôle de référent du mouvement
dans leur commune par ailleurs trois
candidats ont été investis par le
conseil national du mouvement démocrate
à villepreux maisons laffitte et le chez
nero concours là vous avez
porter une manière nouvelle et faire de
la politique et notamment parce que
c'est vraiment un sujet que nos citoyens
appellent de leurs voeux
porter des propositions sur la
transition écologique en frais sur cette
commune qui est une commune nouvelle
première élection en cas de victoire les
candidats ayant signé le pacte
s'engagent à exercer leur mandat selon
les principes qu'ils regroupent à partir
du lundi 28 octobre le conseil
départemental du modem se réunira tous
les mois pour statuer sur les demandes
de soutien et d'investiture